und in berlin bin ich jetzt zum gespräch
verbunden und freue mich dass er sich
zeit nimmt mit fabio die nazi das
ehemalige abgeordnete des europäischen
parlaments des deutschen bundestages und
jetzt freischaffender autor und ich
glaube nach eigener aussage finanz
detektiv nicht richtig gelesen habe er
dem assi wenn es etwas zu untersuchung
gab im finanzgeschehen international
dann waren sie mit dabei kann man so
sagen das muss ich einführen glaube ich
ergänzen panama papers lux leaks aber
auch wirecard da haben sie mitgewirkt
insofern setzt sich jetzt der richtige
mann um das jetzt zu beurteilen was wir
uns vornehmen comex ich glaube wir
müssen ganz generell beginn comics ist
ja sowas wie die lizenz zum gelddrucken
gewesen 1999 macht der bundesfinanzhof
einen relativ kapitalen fehler einen
sehr teuren fehler und ist eine
einladung ausspricht eine einladung an
finanzhaie aus wie ist das ganz konkret
abgelaufen wenn man das in wenigen
sätzen skizzieren soll
nun comics das sind aktiendeals bei den
investoren aktien rund um den dividenden
stichtag also dann wenn die
gewinnbeteiligung an die aktionäre
ausgezahlt wird herumschieben so dass
der staat nicht mehr weiß wer der
eigentliche eigentümer ist und die
lassen sich dann mehrfach
kapitalertragssteuern erstatten die sie
nicht gezahlt oder nur einmal gezahlt
haben das können sie sich so vorstellen
wie wenn ich es in den supermarkt gehe
eine bierflasche abgebe den pfandbon
nehmer auf den kopierer lege und meine
freunde zu supermarktkasse schicke um
abzukassieren mit dem unterschied dass
es nicht um flaschen von sondern um
milliarden geht es gibt schätzungen
sprechen von einem zweistelligen
milliardenbetrag das ganze so zu sagen
hat ja fast zwei jahrzehnte gedauert bis
das sozusagen ernsthafte versuche gab
auch das zu stoppen mittlerweile gibt es
entscheidungen vom bundesgerichtshof vom
bundesfinanzhof dass diese praxis
illegalen ist aber trotzdem warum hat
diesen zauber erst so spät jemand
gestoppt
nun es gab auch erheblichen einfluss der
bankenlobby es gab zum beispiel ein
schreiben der bankenlobby dass auch
gerichtet wurde an die bundesregierung
wo sie im kern auf die gesetzeslücke die
sie damals so gesehen haben der
bundesgerichtshof sagt es gab keine
lücke das war schon immer illegal wo sie
darauf verwiesen haben und dann haben
sie gleich einen lösungsvorschlag
angeboten der aber im kern
das ganze hat weiter laufen lassen und
das hat die regierung so eins zu eins
übernommen und das zeigt man sollte eben
nicht die brandstifter zu feuerwehr
machen und lobbyisten direkt gesetze
schreiben lassen das heißt wir reden
hier ein gewisser weise auch über ein
system versagen aber dieses system
versagen hat durchaus verschiedene
akteure es waren ja in diesem ganzen
zeitraum durchaus verschiedene
finanzminister wenn man sie mal
aufzählen von eichel über steinbrück
schäubles da waren ja durchaus
unterschiedliche in charts kommen wir
mal zu olaf scholz der vor seiner
kanzlerschaft finanzminister war und
davor erster bürgermeister von hamburg
welche belege gibt es bisher auch aus
ihrer betrachtung für ein fehlverhalten
seinerseits
nun ist es so dass das finanzamt in
hamburg damals im jahr 2016 740
millionen euro tatbeute der warburg bank
zurückfordern wollte auch ein
umfangreiches gutachten erstellt hat
sich auf neuere rechtsprechung des
finanzgerichts hessen berufen hat auch
die betriebsprüfer der warburg-bank vom
finanzamt sie wollten diese tatbeute
einziehen und eine finanzbeamten daniela
p die gegen die nun auch ermittelt wird
die soll herrn olearius an der
miteigentümer der bank ausgerichtet
haben es können jetzt nur noch die
politik helfen kurz darauf gab es ein
treffen von olearius mit iphones
pawelczyk und johannes kahrs den
früheren spd-bundestagsabgeordneten und
die haben dann einen kontakt zu herrn
scholz hergestellt es sollte ein
vorbereitender auf das treffen und dann
gab es drei treffen von herrn scholz mit
herrn olearius und das ist schon
bemerkenswert weil er schon selbst
gesagt er verstehe gar nicht wie man auf
die idee hätte kommen können dass comex
jemals legal gewesen sei warum trifft er
sich dann mit einem beschuldigten in
einem ermittlungsverfahren dreimal und
hat danach erinnerungslücken verweigert
antworten im parlament bzw offenbart die
treffen nicht trotz mehrfacher
nachfragen und dann kommt hinzu dass er
zum telefonhörer gegriffen hat er tempo
jahres angerufen und ihn gebeten ein
schreiben dass bereits im finanzamt
vorlag an den damaligen finanzsenator
peter tschentscher zu geben und diese
schreiben ist dann in die
finanzverwaltung mit den an mehr das
finanzhaus herunter gewandert kurz
darauf kippte die entscheidung die
finanzbeamten wurde einbestellt in die
finanzbehörde das hamburger
finanzministerium und revidierte ihre
entscheidung von daher ist die
indizienkette doch sehr dicht
tatsächlich ist es sozusagen immer die
frage dann eines nachweises ich spreche
von der indizienkette insofern wenn wir
noch abschließend eine einschätzung
treffen müssten die es noch werden kann
also es sind jetzt der e-mail-verkehr
durchsucht worden auch der
e-mail-verkehr der büroleiterin es gibt
diese differenten aussagen offenbar in
einem geheimprotokoll des
finanzausschusses bei einer sitzung bei
der sie auch zugegen waren wenn ich das
richtig war es und es gibt sozusagen
jetzt die differenz zwischen dem was
eingeräumt wird und dem was
möglicherweise belegbar ist wie ein tanz
werden
es kann sehr eng werden insbesondere da
ja hier die ermittler im zug sind es
jetzt auch strafprozesse gibt wo auch
harry olearius vielleicht sich überlegt
wer auspackt wenn ihm eben bis zu zehn
jahre haft drohen es ist so dass ich bei
allen drei sitzungen im bundestag
anwesend war ich habe diese auch selbst
beantragt ich darf über die geheimnisse
zum nicht sprechen aber in den medien
stand das dort auf einmal konkrete
erinnerung von herrn scholz da waren und
bei einer weiteren bei einer dritten
sitzung hat er dann gesagt er habe keine
konkreten erinnerungen an diese treffen
insofern hat er sich dort in
widersprüche verwickelt die sind evident
und er scholz hat selbst gesagt dass die
weiterleitung eines schreibens an die
warburg-bank die sei durch ihn nicht
erfolgt in die finanzverwaltung weil das
als politischer einfluss hätte
interpretiert werden können genau das
hat seinen finanzsenator tschentscher
aber nachweislich gemacht insofern ist
für mich belegt herr scholz hat die
unwahrheit im bundestag gesagt und es
wurde einfluss genommen auf der
steuerverfahren danke für ihre klare
position hier heute im phoenix gespräch
das war fabio di massa autor und
ehemalige abgeordnete der linken im
deutschen bundestag und dem europäischen
parlament herzlichen dank ich habe zu
danken